we we have had our fury and our
frustrations in these past months and at
this convention but frankly I welcome
the contrast with the smug and dull and
empty event which will doubtless take
place here in Miami next month
[Applause]
we chose this struggle we reformed our
party and we let the people in
[Applause]
and so we stand today not as a
collection of backroom strategists not
as a tool of ITT or any other special
interest
so let our opponents stand on the status
quo while we seek to refresh the
American spirit let the opposition
collect their ten million dollars in
secret money from the privileged view
and let us find 1 million ordinary
Americans who will contribute $25 each
to this campaign a million member Club
with members who will not expect special
favors for themselves but a better land
for us all
[Applause]
Fitz's and in the music of our children
we are told to everything there is a
season and a time to every purpose under
heaven and for America the time has come
at last this is the time for truth not
falsehood in a democratic nation no one
likes to say that his inspiration came
from secret arrangements behind closed
doors but in a sense that is how my
candidacy began I am here as your
candidate tonight in large part because
during four administration's of both
parties a terrible war has been charted
behind closed doors
[Applause]
I want those doors open and I want that
war closed
and I make these pledges above all
others the doors of government will be
open and that war will be closed truth
is a habit of integrity not a strategy
of politics and if we nurture the habit
of truth in this campaign we will
continue to be truthful once we are in
the White House let us say to Americans
as Woodrow Wilson said in his first
campaign of 1912 let me inside the
government and I will tell you what is
going on there
[Applause]
Wilson believed and I believe that the
destiny of America is always safer in
the hands of the people than in the
conference rooms of any elite so let us
give our let us give our country the
chance to elect a government that will
see and speak the truth or this is a
time for the truth in the life of this
country
[Applause]
and this is also a time not for death
but for life in 1968 many Americans
thought they were voting to bring our
sons home from Vietnam in peace and
since then 20,000 of our sons have come
home in coffins I have no secret plan
for peace I have a public plan and as
one whose heart has eight for the past
ten years over the agony of Vietnam
I will halt the senseless bombing of
Indochina on inaugural day
there will be no more Asian children
running a blaze from bombed-out schools
there will be no more talk of bombing
the dikes or the cities of the north and
within 90 days of my inauguration every
American soldier and every American
prisoner will be out of the jungle and
out of their cells and back home in
America where they belong
[Applause]
and then let us resolve that never again
will we send the precious young blood of
this country that died trying to prop up
a corrupt military dictatorship abroad
this is also the time to turn away from
excessive preoccupation overseas to the
rebuilding of our own nation America
must be restored to her proper role in
the world but we can do that only
through the recovery of confidence in
ourselves I believe that the greatest
contribution American that can now make
to our fellow mortals is to heal our own
great but very deeply trouble and we
must respond we must respond to that
ancient command physician heal thyself
[Applause]
it is necessary in an age of nuclear
power and hostile forces that we'd be
militarily strong America must never
become a second-rate nation as one who
has tasted the bitter fruits of our
weakness before Pearl Harbor 1941
I give you my pledge that if I become
the president of the United States
America will keep its defenses alert and
fully sufficient to meet any danger
[Applause]
not only for ourselves but for those who
deserve and need the shield of our
strength our old allies in Europe and
elsewhere including the people of Israel
who will always have thy help to hold
their promised land
and yet I believe that every man and
woman in this convention Hall knows that
for 30 years we have been so absorbed
with fear and danger from abroad that we
have permitted our own house to fall
into disarray we must now show that
peace and prosperity can exist side by
side indeed each now depends on the
existence of the other National Strength
includes the credibility of our system
in the eyes of our own people as well as
the credibility of our deterrent in the
eyes of others abroad
[Applause]
national security includes schools for
our children as well as silos for our
missiles it includes the health of our
families as much as the size of our
bombs the safety of our streets and the
condition of our cities and not just the
engines of war
[Applause]
and if we someday choke on the pollution
of our own air there will be little
consolation and leaving behind a dying
continent ring with steel
[Applause]
[Music]
oh well protecting ourselves abroad let
us form a more perfect union here at
home and this is the time for that task
[Applause]
[Music]
we must also make this a time of justice
and jobs for all our people for more
than three and a half years we have
tolerated stagnation and a rising level
of joblessness with more than five
million of our best workers unemployed
at this very moment surely this is the
most false and wasteful economics of all
our deep our deep need is not providing
us but for new housing and hospitals or
facilities to combat pollution and take
us home from work for better products
able to compete on vigorous world
markets the highest single domestic
priority of the next administration will
be to ensure that every American able to
work has a job to do
[Applause]
[Music]
that job guarantee will and must depend
upon a reinvigorated private economy
free that last from the uncertainties
and burdens of war but it is our firm
commitment that whatever employment the
private sector does not provide the
federal government will either stimulate
or provide itself
[Applause]
whatever it takes this country is going
back to words America cannot exist with
most of our people working and paying
taxes to support too many others mired
in a demeaning and hopeless welfare mess
[Applause]
[Music]
therefore we intend to begin by putting
millions back to work and after that is
done we will assure to those unable to
work an income fully adequate to a
decent life
[Applause]
now beyond this a program to put America
back to work demands that work be
properly rewarded that means the end of
a system of economic controls in which
labor is depressed but prices and
corporate profits run sky-high
[Applause]
it means a system of national health
insurance so that a worker can afford
decent health care for himself and his
family
[Applause]
it means real enforcement of the laws so
that the drug racketeers are put behind
bars and our streets are once again safe
for our family
and above all above all honest work must
be rewarded by a fair and just tax
system
tax system today does not reward hard
work it penalizes it inherited or
invested well frequently multiplies
itself while paying no taxes at all but
wages on the assembly line or in farming
the land these hard-earned dollars are
taxed to the very last penny there is a
depletion allowance for oil wells but no
depletion for the farmer who feeds us or
the worker who serves us all
[Applause]
the administration tells us that we
should not discuss tax reform in an
election year they would prefer to keep
all discussion of the tax laws in closed
rooms where the administration its
powerful friends and their paid
lobbyists can turn every effort at
reform into a new loophole for the rich
and powerful but an election year is the
people's year to speak and this year the
people are going to ensure that the tax
system is changed so that work is
rewarded and so that those who derive
the highest benefits will pay their fair
share
rather than slipping through the
loopholes at the expense of the rest of
us
[Applause]
so let us stand for justice and jobs and
against special privilege and this is
the time to stand for those things that
are close to the American spirit we are
not content with things as they are we
reject the view of those who say America
love it or leave it we reply let us
change it so we may love it the more
and this is the time it is the time for
this land to become again a witness to
the world for what is just and Noble in
human affairs it is time to live more
with faith and less with fear with an
abiding confidence that can sweep away
the strongest barriers between us and
teach us that we are truly brothers and
sisters so join with me in this campaign
LEM senator Eagleton and me your
strength and your support and together
we will call America home to the ideals
that nourished us from the very
beginning
[Music]
from secrecy and deception in high
places come home America from military
spending so wasteful that it weakens our
nation come home America from the
entrenchment of special privilege and
tax favoritism from the waste of idle
hands to the joy of useful labor from
the prejudice based on race and sex from
the loneliness of the aging poor and the
despair of the neglected sick come home
America come home to the affirmation
that we have a dream come home to the
conviction that we can move our country
forward come home to the belief that we
can seek a newer world and let us be
joyful in the hope homecoming for this
land is your land this land is my land
from California to the New York island
from the redwood forest to the Gulf
Stream waters this land was made for you
and me
[Applause]
the lettuce close on this note may God
grant each one of us the wisdom to
cherish this good lamb and to meet the
great challenge that beckons us home and
now is the time to meet that challenge
goodnight and Godspeed
Road to the White House rewind runs
every Sunday at 10 a.m. Eastern for the
next several weeks we'll feature
highlights from the Democratic and
Republican conventions back to 1948
this is American history TV only on
c-span three
tonight on American history TV author
Tammy Ingraham discusses her upcoming
book the wickedest city in America sex
race and organized crime the Jim Crow
South here's a preview this one is
interesting because his reply is a
little bit less firm of a no than he
would be giving to people later on
he simply tells him that time won't
permit them to come to every place but
in every small town where there might be
some problems but he indicates that he's
interested in learning more about what's
going on in Phoenix City now unbeknownst
to luttrell probably he was already
corresponding with Albert Patterson and
Kefauver knew very well what was going
on in Phoenix City and I do think he
took a special interest in those those
letters and they're elsewhere there's
some other correspondents like this but
they're little memos like this scattered
throughout the papers the memo I guess
either saying that Hugh Bentley had
called or somebody had called and
mention Hugh Bentley's name he's the guy
whose house was fire bombed by the mob
and below it you see the name of point
shepherd point shepherd was the main
kingpin in Phoenix City and the guy
working for him who bombed the house his
name was Tommy dynamite Capps each
person had a specialty there was the
safecracker and you didn't step on the
safecrackers territory Tommy dynamite
Katz I wish I had his mugshot I do have
a copy of it from the State Archives
it's a it's it's interesting and his
long list of known activities but uh but
he was there he was there guy they
called in to to blow things up but and
there are a lot of snippets of
information like this scattered
throughout so I really got the
impression that a lot of people were
Horace ponding with Kefauver and that he
knew a great deal about what's going on
in Phoenix City
watch the entire program tonight
starting at 7:00 Eastern here on
American history TV on c-span 3
watch c-span's live coverage of the
Republican National Convention beginning
next Monday in Cleveland and tonight at
8:00 Eastern we'll take a look at past
Republican conventions including the
contentious 1976 Republican convention
in Kansas City Missouri starting with
the rules debate where a proposed rule
would require President Gerald Ford to
select his running mate prior to the
presidential balloting process will also
feature speeches from the convention
from President Ford and former
California Governor Ronald Reagan we
have just heard a call to arms
based on that platform and a call to us
to really be successful in communicating
and reveal to the American people the
difference between this platform and the
platform of the opposing party which is
nothing but a revamp and a reissue and a
running of a Late Late Show of the thing
that we've been hearing from them for
the last 40 years the 1952 convention in
Chicago with Dwight Eisenhower you have
summoned me on behalf of millions of
your fellow Americans to lead a great
crusade for freedom in America and
freedom in the world I know something of
the solemn responsibility of leading a
crusade I have led one known for his
military career rather than his
political expertise he was selected as
the Republican nominee and he later won
the 1952 election and the 1996
Republican convention in San Diego with
former Kansas Senator Bob Dole passed
national conventions tonight at 8:00
Eastern on c-span
all weekend American History TV is
featuring Cleveland host of the
Republican National Convention that
begins on Monday the Cuyahoga River is
sometimes called the river that caught
fire
after the story of an oil slick fire
made national news in 1969 hosted by our
charter communications cable partners
c-span city store staff recently visited
many sites showcasing the city's rich
history learn more about Cleveland all
weekend here on American history TV so
we're currently looking at a standard
oil delivery wagon that would have been
used to deliver products various oil
products from the Standard Oil Company
here in Cleveland Ohio and on the
sideboard we see various product
packaging for other products that were
either you know made by or eventually
made by Standard Oil out of the refining
process of petroleum here in Cleveland
area Standard Oil of course was formed
by john d rockefeller in 1870 and
quickly became one of the largest
petroleum companies in the United States
and at john d rockefeller was a
brilliant businessman who had moved to
the cleveland area with his family as a
young boy grew up in the Cleveland area
in boarding school and then eventually
working in various companies and in the
petroleum industry until founding his
own company the Standard Oil Company and
Standard Oil actually comes from John
Rockefellers idea and and desired a
standardized actually kerosene kerosene
was what most homes were using as a
lighting oil in their lamps and at the
time kerosene was somewhat dangerous
there was no standardization of it some
of it would burn hotter and quicker than
others and it would lead to fires in
home
and so john d rockefeller was really
interested in in standardizing that and
making a safe product for americans and
that's really what he was able to
achieve with standard oil and even went
so far as to build their own safety
lamps to burn standard oil in
standardized kerosene oil in in the
homes and this led to rockefeller
quickly becoming one of the wealthiest
men in America and also becoming one of
the most hated men in America as they
called him the way john d rockefeller
ran his business the way he took over
other petroleum industries led to a very
bad public image his business practices
were well known as not the best in
American business and it was at that
point where his advisers told him he
needed to appear appear even more
charitable than he already was and he
began kind of a his own campaign where
when he was out on the streets walking
around meeting people talking to people
he would give out dimes and you know
there became a very large legend behind
rockefeller dimes and that was really
you know to be handed a dime at the time
you know the early 1900's when
Rockefeller was doing this he was giving
away actually a large amount of money
and you know if you think about you know
a steel industry worker who might have
been you know making a couple hundred
dollars a week you know a dime was a
significant amount of money especially
when he'd hand it to children and you
know children were able to then go out
and buy things and and it was all
because of mr. Rockefeller he looked
again like a good guy rather than this
bad businessman everyone had come to
know him as so Standard Oil the the
company that Rockefeller founded here in
Cleveland quickly became successful
obviously making Rockefeller the the
wealthy man he was but it also impacted
Cleveland economically
it it brought money into the city but
also the ability of Rockefeller to be
able to pay his employees a decent wage
and allow them to live a good life here
in Cleveland it was just another one of
those industries here in Cleveland at
the time that was doing so well like the
auto industry that the citizens of
Cleveland had a very you know good
quality of life in this city at the time
thanks to these major industries be it
the auto industry or the petroleum
industry that Standard Oil was in
bringing that wealth into the city
our city store staff recently traveled
to Cleveland to learn about its rich
history learn more about the city and
other stops on our tour at c-span org
slash cities tour you're watching
American history TV all weekend every
weekend on c-span three
so I had a rough upbringing and I got
involved in the streets and met some
friends and they were selling drugs so
it was like the thing to do and I
started selling drugs we start selling
marijuana
we saw some mescaline times cocaine and
then crack cocaine came out and we
started selling that so I was in the
streets from the age of 13 to 18 years
old five years
Sunday night on cue and a 21-year
veteran of the NYPD Cory Piggy's
discusses his book once a comp the
street the law two worlds one man he
talks about his former life as a drug
dealer and as a police officer and you
know I criticize police a lot but when I
criticize I'm talking about the bad
police and that's the small percentage
overwhelming majority cops they just
coming to work doing their job but you
don't have about them you hear about the
you know the Tamir rice the Eric garner
case is the key girl in the pink out you
hear about the bad cops or bad policing
and once the law enforcement start
weeding them out because every time you
see one of these cases on black America
you look at the person's background
seven complaints of use of force five
substantiated
he's been cursive is the guy was a mess
and we don't find out about today kill
somebody Sunday night at 8:00 Eastern on
c-span's Q&A
the Smithsonian's National Air and Space
Museum opened 40 years ago on July 1st
1976 leading up to the anniversary
American history TVs real America is
showing a series of NASA films up next
from 1979 planet Mars this half-hour
film documents the search to understand
our solar system's most earth-like
planet the film includes an overview of
NASA's Mariner flybys of the Red Planet
between 1964 and 1971 and the Viking
mission that landed to craft on the
surface in 1976
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
of all the planets in the solar system
earth in Mars the third and fourth
planets from the Sun are the most
similar
but despite the similarities Mars is
essentially like no other planet it is a
unique world it was an elusive and
baffling planet to astronomers for
hundreds of years
to early telescopes it appeared to be a
small red sphere later estimated to be
about half the size of Earth one of the
earliest known representations of a
planet drawn in 1659 indicated markings
on the surface and by the movement of
these dark patches that cost the disk it
was shown that Mars rotated on its axis
in a period only a little longer than
its about 24 and 1/2 hours it was
observed to that the tilt of its axis
like the Earth's exposes its polar
regions alternately to the sunlight thus
each hemisphere has a summer and winter
period and since Mars orbits the Sun in
687 Earth days one Martian year and each
of its seasons is almost twice as long
as Earth's later mappings of the planet
displayed light and dark regions
identified erroneously as continents and
oceans the landmasses red as the
sandstone districts on earth the water a
greenish blue in 1877 an Italian
astronomer Giovanni Schiaparelli is
tethered what he called kilala or
channels resembling he said the finest
threads of a spider's web drawn across
the disk in America Percival Lowell
founded an observatory to study these
Martian features massive irrigation
systems he called them designed to carry
water from the melting ice caps to the
major centers of a dying civilization
science fiction writers populated the
cities the terrible creatures of heroic
science with skills beyond earth man's
dreams
in the 1960s three Mariner spacecraft
flew by Mars and photographed about 10%
of the surface yarn with the canals
found with the city gone a brilliant and
sinister Martians
the photographs revealed at cratered
landscape much like the moon waterless
and apparently hostile to life but in
1971 the Mariner 9 spacecraft orbited
Mars and transmitted more than 7,000
photographs of the planet to earth the
extensive mapping revealed a new and
unexpected world the southern hemisphere
seen by earlier spacecraft flattened and
gouged by the impact of meteorites the
northern hemisphere a vast plain with
few craters and rising from the plane a
great dome called Tarsus topped by giant
volcanoes the plateau that joins the two
hemispheres is cut by a vast and deep
canyon and by channels were the
characteristic patterns of stream beds
on earth some of the channels suggested
that water may once have flowed on Mars
and thus life might have evolved and
possibly adapted to Mars changing
conditions
and then in 1975 two Viking spacecraft
were launched each of which was
programmed to land a robot on the
Martian surface one of its principal
objectives was to test for the presence
or absence of living organisms
a communication system linked the
spacecraft to the Mission Control and
computing Center in Pasadena California
On June 19th 1976 the first Viking
arrived in the vicinity of Mars after a
year-long journey of more than 400
million miles
once in orbit its cameras were turned to
a detailed examination of the landing
area imaging teams on earth scanned some
800 photographs covering a territory
about the size of Texas
the chosen landing site was a fat
expense with a few impact craters one of
the lowest regions on the surface i'm
july 2019 surprises flight controllers
order the land to separate from the
orbiter returns of mars great distance
away the signal traveling at the speed
of light 186,000 miles per second took
19 minutes to reach the spacecraft
this necessitated a completely automated
system on board by carrying out the
landing maneuver during the Landers
descent its instruments analyzed the
properties of the thin Martian
atmosphere
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
good roll attitude hold close to mortar
fire fire mortar fire
[Music]
what I want him to think we just playing
its 105 little man freezing thing
before my precinct
877 feet per second a short roam over
parachute separation
105 23:46
[Music]
366 beat in 73 feet per second
ACS is close to vertical ever 3 for
Dutch now
[Music]
[Applause]
yes we have a touchdown time of 12 hours
12 minutes Jellico
zero seven decimal one track of God very
well done outstanding straight
navigation perfect I'm assuming that we
must be sitting right on the X so that's
the smooth area so everybody just did
fabulous in' couldn't be more pleased
thank you
25 seconds after landing one of the two
cameras was initiated and scan the first
picture of the martian surface about a
half an hour later when it started to
come back from the orbiter and we got
the first seven lines on the TV monitors
you could see grey and white light
levels and we knew there was something
there and all of a sudden we were
looking at the surface of Mars and it
was clear it wasn't dusty it was sharp
and when we got to the end of that first
picture with the dust and small pebbles
in the footpad it was just it was really
a miracle in an instant the picture was
wiped off the TV monitors and behind it
came the filling in of the second
picture a long panoramic view that
covers 300 degrees and extends from the
lander to the horizon it disclosed a
sector of the basin called crisi
Phoenicia
covered with sand or dust and littered
with rocks
the following day viking sent back the
first color picture a fine dust red or
yellow brown covers the ground the sky
is a light tint of the same color due to
the particles of dust suspended in the
air
forty-five days after these historic
events Viking two landed in an area
4,600 miles northwest of Viking one's
landing site a vast pain littered - with
rocks resembling those on earth produced
by volcanic processes or by meteorite
impact
while the Landers conducted experiment
on the surface
the orbiters swinging around the planet
measured variations in moisture and
temperature and took high-resolution
photographs of the Martian terrain
[Music]
[Music]
all and a half billion years ago the
planets were formed from the gas and
dust of the solar nebula
[Music]
in the formation of a planet heat his
release them remains embedded in the
growing mass because the heat can't
escape as rapidly as the mass is growing
a point is reached eventually for the
interior melts on Mars the heavier
material sank for the center and the
lighter material rose to form a crust at
the surface and this crust contained ice
and other condensates
a later stage may have occurred where
molten rock intruded into the crust and
melted the i'ts causing a slurry of
water and rock and duct to flow across
the surface some observers believed that
such a process may have been the cause
of the major channels which we see on
the surface of Mars today but others
believe that in Mars first billion years
the atmosphere may have been warm and
dense enough for rain to fall and for
rivers to flow
gradually the original thick wet and
warm blanket of the atmosphere evolved
into the thin dry carbon dioxide
atmosphere we find there today my tolls
of Mars low atmospheric pressure and low
temperatures water can't exist in liquid
form it must either freeze or evaporate
but while there are no oceans or rivers
on Mars there is more water in total
than anyone had expected the residual
polar cap in the north which remains
after the hottest part of the northern
summer his water ice makes the dust and
the measurements of the seasonal
behavior of water vapor over the planet
suggests that there is a vast reservoir
of ice beneath the surface so that one
can think of the residual polar cap as
the tip of an iceberg protruding from a
sea of rock at lower latitudes a water
vapour condenses to form clouds that
ride high in the atmosphere or swirl
around the slopes of Martian volcanoes
and further south in the canyons and
valleys there is frequently a nice haze
seem to form and evaporate in the early
hours of the morning as the Sun warms
the atmosphere
on earth the oceans heat and moisture
and the heat and air currents over land
masses interact to produce complex
weather patterns on Mars because of the
absence of large bodies of water and of
massive cloud covers the weather doesn't
vary much from day to day like a remote
weather station on earth Vikings
meteorology instrument measures Mars
atmospheric pressure temperature wind
speed and wind direction temperatures
range from minus 122 degrees Fahrenheit
just after dawn to minus 22 degrees in
the mid-afternoon light winds from the
east in the late afternoon changed to
light winds from the southwest after
midnight maximum wind speed is 15 miles
per hour but in the early summer the
heating of dust particles in the air
generates violent dust storms and the
whole regions of the planet
driven by winds that reach 150 miles an
hour they may blanket the entire planet
in a few days
in order to understand the geology and
physics of windblown particles on Mars
we're conducting a series of experiments
using this this enormous space
environment chamber here at NASA's Ames
Research Center we've placed an
open-circuit wind tunnel in this chamber
and we're able to operate at atmospheric
surface pressures comparable to those on
Mars in this particular series of
experiments we have placed a crater
model in the tunnel floor and we want to
determine the zones of erosion and
deposition around the crater in this
particular case we're going to let the
wind blow across the crater and see what
those zones of erosion and deposition
are like the light and dark streets
associated with craters are the most
common features on the surface of Mars
related to wind the light streaks are
deposits of fallout from the global dust
storms the dark streaks our regions on
which a thin layer of light material has
been removed revealing a darker
underlying surface these streaks serve
as wind markers their patterns define
the wind flow
to the geologist the features seen in
the tens of thousands of photographs
transmitted by Viking or the visible
signs of the enormous forces and
processes that have shaped the surface
admire the excavation of large basins
and craters by the impact of meteorites
and asteroids the raising of mountains
by the action of volcanoes the faulting
and subsidence of the crust as the
planet expanded
and the cutting of channels by water or
abrasive particles driven by winds over
a period of tens of millions of years
the key to the agent sequence of these
features is found in the number and
condition of craters those areas with
fewer skaters are assumed to be the
youngest here a fresh crater over lies
an ancient eroded one here the rim of a
crater is eroded by water or wind and
here adjacent to a fresh crater is one
of a cluster of crater rings craters
that have been buried to varying depths
over millions of years the repeated
flows of lava built the volcanic
mountains of Mars 12 are larger than any
on earth the largest olympus mons rises
three times higher than Mount Everest
and is broad enough to cover the whole
chain of volcanoes that form the
Hawaiian Islands the great gash that
cuts through Mars equatorial zone is
Valles Marineris a mighty canyon system
that extends over an area more than
3,000 miles long and up to 400 miles
wide and drops four miles below the flat
cratered surface of the plateau canyon
walls are gonna dissect it by tributary
canyons or scarred by catastrophic
landslides leaving steep cliffs and
great fractured surfaces extending for
30 miles on the canyon floor is a field
of sand dunes suggesting that some of
the debris produced by the collapse of
the canyon walls was removed by wind
these ancient channels that resemble dry
riverbeds on earth could have been
formed by primeval rain storms but the
vast channel system that starred in
areas of collapsed terrain with broad
stream lines extending hundreds of miles
across the lowlands and teardrop-shaped
Ireland soaring to thousands of feet
above the channel bed testified to a
process without any parallel order
viking also photographed the two
cratered moons of Mars Phobos the inner
moon marked by striations which on
closer view resolved into grooves
several miles long and Deimos a smaller
outer lone Viking traveling at 3,800
miles an hour and passing only 30 miles
away could observe boulders on the
moon's surface some as large as 100 feet
across the geologic record of the planet
suggests that Mars like the earth has
experience periodic changes of climate
the best evidence of this is seen in the
strange spiral patterns of Mars polar
regions the dark bands are scarps or
cliffs of bare ground within the north
polar ice cap on each scarp are numerous
small terraces eroded from layered rocks
this is a model of layered terrain an
area about 40 miles across it is
believed that the large scarps and the
small terraces represent two different
cycles of climatic change which occur
simultaneously because of Mars
oscillation in its orbit about the Sun
the polar regions are alternately warm
and cold for periods of tens of
thousands to millions of years during
the cold period mixtures of dust and ice
were deposited in a series of near
horizontal layers obscuring the
underlying topography then a period of
warmer climate followed and erosion
Syrian cutting deep valleys into the icy
mass of the polar caps after the erosion
cycle new layers were laid down and
another episode of erosion followed this
oblique truncating of one set of
terraces by another indicates that the
climate turns on and off
first geological evidence for cyclic
apply marek change on a planet other
than the earth
the speculations about changes in the
atmosphere and climate were closely
related to the notion that life in some
form might exist on Mars on earth life
developed several billion years ago at a
time when the overall properties of Mars
and the earth were very similar
now over the ensuing billions of years
Mars and the earth involved separately
however Mars today still has chemicals
on its surface and atmosphere
temperatures and pressures within which
we believe life can exist the Viking
Lander was equipped with three life
detection experiments designed to test
for chemical changes caused by life
processes that are familiar to us on
earth on earth all living organisms
interact with the environment through a
process called metabolism animals for
example take oxygen from the environment
and use it to combust food thereby
obtaining energy at the same time they
release carbon dioxide and other waste
products into the environment green
plants and some microorganisms do the
reverse in the process of photosynthesis
they remove carbon dioxide from the
environment and using sunlight as the
energy source they convert the carbon
dioxide into organic matter and release
oxygen into the environment if the
experiments on Mars indicated that
similar processes were occurring then we
would presume the possible existence of
organisms on that planet
well our results are NARS in certain
experiments gave us data that seemed to
mimic the metabolism of living organisms
however careful analysis of that data
indicates that it is probably the result
of chemicals rather than biological
processes
on earth all biological systems are
based on organic chemistry and it was
believed that life on Mars would also be
based on organic compounds the notion
was strengthened when experiments on
earth demonstrated that organic
materials can be formed under simulated
Martian conditions we use finely
powdered minerals like those expected on
the Martian surface then we added traces
of water vapor and radioactive carbon
monoxide at low pressure to simulate
margin sunlights who use irradiated the
mixture with light from a xenon arc lamp
when we heated the sample and captured
the gases that were formed or radiation
counters showed that the carbon monoxide
and water had been converted to organic
compounds but vikings instruments failed
to detect organic compounds of any kind
that fact in the opinion of some
observers has increased the odds against
the existence of living organisms on
Mars
if we were able to do a thousand
experiments different experiments on
Mars and to do these in a wide variety
of places on Mars in the canyons on the
polar caps in some deep areas of the
surface and if in all of these
experiments we've got negative results
then the answer to the question is there
life on Mars would almost certainly be
no but on the basis of just a few
experiments done at only two sites very
bland sites on the planet I think that
would be unscientific for us to come to
that conclusion all we can really say
for sure is that we have run across a
very interesting chemistry a kind of
chemistry that we do not see in surface
samples from the earth or surface
samples from the moon and that's about
where we are at the moment
today in laboratories across the nation
scientists are trying to simulate the
results that we obtained on Mars some of
the scientists are concentrating on
irradiation experiments to see whether
solar energy acting on Mars could have
produced chemicals to account for the
results other experiments are assuming
that these chemicals were there and are
testing one or another of these
chemicals to see whether they can
account for the results that were
obtained
[Music]
the question of life on Mars is only one
of the inexhaustible number of questions
for which we continue to seek answers in
States questions about the origin and
evolution of the solar system of our own
planet and our own species
[Music]
the search for answers is a goal of
planetary exploration and the journeys
of our spacecraft to the near and far
reaches of the solar system are
beginning to provide some of the answers
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]